hello everyone and welcome to a true
positional Masterpiece from yesterday's
Pro chess League it's uh the levit of
Chess Wizards versus the Indian yogis uh
and it's a Daniel dubo versus vaishali
yeah it's a it's a brilliant game I hope
you guys enjoy it uh let's check it out
uh doob opens with Pawn to D4 we have
Knight to F6 by vashali Knight to F3
Pawn to D5 and C4 uh we have Pawn to E6
going for the standard Queen's Gambit
declined and the bishop to G5 the
standard way uh or the traditional
variation Bishop to A7 we have E3
castles and now Queen to C2 now this is
a very very rare move here usually
Knights the C3 is played or you can
capture on D5 or something like that but
Queen to C2 is a very rare we have Pawn
to C5 striking against the center d-cap
presents C5 and now Queen to A5 with
check with Knight bd2 Queen captures on
C5 and now there is one game where Rook
the C1 was played it was played in 2019
between Dmitry and reiken and Michael
Adams uh the game ended in a draw uh but
here we have Ponte A3 by Daniel and it
is now as of move nine that we have a
completely new game so the characters on
C4 and now Bishop captures on C4 and
vaishali goes for Pawn to B5 she wants
to trade Queens here uh with Bishop back
to D3 you could also consider B4 here I
uh it's um a very odd that dubo did not
consider B4 here but okay uh Bishop back
to D3 by Charlie trades characters
captures into Bishop to B7 and it's a
pretty equal position uh everything is
pretty much the same the material is
completely even and both players have
The Bishop's pair uh one thing that's
different is that vaishali already
advanced her B Pawn all the way to B5 so
she controls more space on the queen
side uh Bishop back to D3 going after
the pawn here and pawn to H6 attacking
Dubose bishop and you can't really trade
to pick up the pawn here because the
opponent B2 will be hanging as well so
just Bishop back to H4 Ponte A6
defending and King to E2 with 9 might be
to D7 Rook H to C1 and of course now you
want to control the C file as well Rook
have to C8 opposing white rook and C1
here at night the B3 and the bishop to
D5 attacking the undefended Knight and
here dubov just trades both uh pairs of
Rooks uh of the board and Rook to C1 now
you could maybe try try uh something
other than trade here but um yeah
trading is good for black as you'll see
a real counters Knight characters and
pawn to G5 attacking the Russian Bishop
to G3 and now Knight the E4 and this is
where it uh really uh becomes
interesting with Bishop to C7 of course
dubo one does not wanna uh give up the
bishop pair he goes Bishop the C7 Bishop
to F6 uh she goes for the B2 pawn and
now Knights the D4 defending the pawn
and now Knight eat the C5 going after
sorry Knight E to C5 going after the
bishop on D3 and here uh dubo should uh
probably figure out a way how to how how
to maybe keep the Bishops but also uh
maybe just improve his position with
moves like Pawn 3 and B4 maybe it's time
to stop
um uh uh you know uh thinking about the
Bishops and he does go Pawn to F3 here
but now Knight to E5 and here again he
should uh figure out a way how to how to
give up the bishop pair but he wants to
keep it Bishop to C2 and now uh vaishali
plays Knight the C4 and it becomes very
very hard to keep your pawns how do you
defend your uh beat you Pawn there's no
good way to do it I move that uh should
allow for an equalish game is spawn to
B3 but here the nil played Pawn to B4
and this is one of the very very few uh
occasions where B4 is not the strongest
move but maybe even the a really bad
movies The Pawn on B4 will be an easy
target for Black's pieces but okay this
is rapid let's not forget that Knight
captures on A3 she wins the A3 pawn and
now Bishop back to D1 uh the the problem
is if you go B captures and C5 then
Bishop captures and D for first
eliminating the defender of the bishop
and if he captures Knight captures and
okay dubo would have a pass C Pawn uh by
the way Charlie would have a past A and
B Pawn and the bishop nicely controlling
all of the squares here the Knight is
beautifully placed also the D4 Pawn is
hanging so this would be just a straight
out winning for her so instead Bishop
back to D1 uh dubov keeps the bishop
pair Knight to D7 now with Bishop to B3
uh offering a trade and now Knight the
C4
uh we ignite the D3 getting the knights
uh the knights into the game Bishop to
E7 now goes after the B4 Pawn as well
now the Knight on D3 cannot move so Pawn
to E4 Bishop back to B7 uh we have
knighted the C2 uh and then now comes
Knight seat to B6 with King to E3 uh
improving the position of the king king
G7 and now Knights the E5 offering a
trade of knights but just Bishop to F6
here we do have a trade Knight captures
Knight captures and Knight the D4 now
it's an excellent Square for the Knight
so Bishop back to E7 and now Knight back
to C2 here dubo needs to keep an eye on
that b for pawn and as you can see it's
not easy defending it there with Bishop
to F6 and now Knight to D4 and now
Bishop to E5 if vaishali repeats uh dubo
will most likely repeat and we will have
a draw by repetition but here we have
Bishop to E5 and finally a trade of
Bishops Bishop captures Knight captures
and now comes Knight the E2
and this is uh it's very hard to to
understand what the dubo wanted with
this Knight they eat to move but they
were both in um in time travel here you
you should just play anything and just
keep the Knight on D4 you need the
Knight on D4 uh to stop the black knight
from coming to C6 from winning the B4
Pawn uh but he played Knight to E2 and
now vaishali just goes after the pawn
there's no stopping that Knight to C6 uh
we have Pawn to G3 she captures on B4
Knight to C3 and now Knight back to C6
with Pawn to F4 and now G captures G
captures and pawn to E5 now trying to
mess a white spawn structure Bishop D5
not allowing the Knight to move e
captures with tracking captors and not
night day five or rather preventing the
knight from moving anywhere other than
A5 or d8 as you can move there to defend
the bishop so here King E5 just
improving the position of your king and
now Pawn to B4 she starts advancing her
past B Pawn Knight A4 and now Bishop the
C6 she wants to force as many trades as
possible as she is up to pawn so if you
if you eliminate the pieces of the board
then the king opponent game is easily
winning uh we have knighted to C5 and
now Bishop to B5 with King to D6 and now
comes Knight to C4 with check and King
the E7 so the F7 Pawn is hanging but
just Knights the E5 nicely defending
that King B6 attacks the Knight Knight
to G6 now stopping the king from
reaching that F7 pawn pawn to E5 and now
Pawn to A5 she continues advancing the
the queen side pawns Knights the B3 and
now Pawn to A4 we have Knight to D4 and
now Bishop to D3 of course uh Daniel
knows it's over here but it is rapid
they're both very low on time so he will
try and get a draw here but the problem
is you cannot reach the pawn and you
cannot Advance the E Pawn so you really
don't have much Choice here uh so here
he tries E6 you want to try anything
here F characters not captures with
check King to F6 and now Knights the C5
attacks the bishop and the pawn but just
a nice calm Bishop to C2 with Knight to
D7 check King to G5 Knights the C5 now
and now Knight the F4 going after the
bishop Bishop C4 and now Pawn to A3
those pawns are unstoppable and of
course dubo will have to give up a piece
to stop the pawns with King to E5 the
show back to B1 now controlling the A2
square and now Knight the A6 going after
the B4 pawn pawn to A2 and now uh dubov
has to give up a piece but at least he
will grab both of the pawns Bishop
captures Bishop captures Knight captures
on B4 and the bishop back to F7 and now
okay uh dubov uh I did grab the two
connected pass pawns but the problem is
even if he somehow sacrifices this
Knight for the pawn uh vaishali still
has a bishop and the Knight and of
course you all know that you can
checkmate with a bishop and the night so
there's really no way to for him to to
save this game I uh other than other
than vaishali uh going for some sort of
a self-mate which is uh which never
happens and maybe you know uh losing on
time so here we have King the E4 King to
G4 Knights the A6 now uh we have Bishop
to D5 with check King to E3 Knight to G2
with check with King to F2 now comes
Bishop captures uh sorry King to H3 King
to G1 and not Knight the H4 we have
knighted to C7 attacking the bishop and
now just the bishop to C4 you don't even
have to worry about this you you can
just go after the pawn with Knight to F3
check but you have to move the bishop at
some point so uh Bishop to C4 was played
with Knight to E8 and now best Knight to
F3 with check this will win the Pawn
King H1 doesn't help you because you
cannot get a stalemate here uh even if
you even if you didn't have a knight you
always have that G1 Square uh but okay
King to F2 was played with Knight
captures on H2 Knight to D6 and now
Bishop to D3 nicely controlling the
Knight King to E3 with Bishop actor B1
and now King to F4 we have Pawn to H5
Knight to F7 and now Pawn to H4 we have
Knight to E5 and the King to G2 with a
king to G5 attacking the pawn and of
course King to G3 defending Knight to C4
we have Knight to F3 with check King to
H5 and now Ponte H3 Knight to E3 here
Bishop to D3 was played knock on skin to
H6 and here by Charlie played Pawn to H2
and he was in this position and move 82
that Daniel dubo resigned the game
uh as there is nothing more to be done
here really nicely done by vaishali
um there's that weird quote I I don't
remember how it goes exactly like uh
maybe even Magnus said it or someone
like the the hardest thing to do in
chess is to prevent your opponent from
showing what he can do and we all we all
know what Daniel dubo can do so here uh
vaishali really uh you know prevented
dubo from from doing anything with the
white pieces and she just outplayed him
uh completely positionally just uh went
for the end game one a nice end game and
uh you know
um over the course of 82 moves in time
travel for both of them uh she
definitely outplayed him uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh interestingly uh Daniel uh played
both against vaishali and her brother
pragnananda as the uh they both
represent the same team uh Prague only
got a draw so uh very nicely done for
for the family against Daniel dubov uh
so yeah there we have it hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Glenn
Beaton and Chris Foster better than
Ronnie uh funky monkey and ravishing
reptiles YouTube for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing uh to check up any wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day